[Applaudissements]
bonjour on vous a dit que j'étais
vétérinaire on ne vous a pas dit que
j'étais vétérinaire depuis plus d'un
demi siècle
voyez c'est une passion qui a envahi mon
esprit et mes tripes
depuis l'âge de 10 ans et je vais vous
faire une confidence en toute immodestie
à l'âge de 15 ans j'étais déjà un très
bon vétérinaire
oui je me souviens je me souviens
pendant le cours de grec avec ma voiture
équipée d'un gyrophare et d'une sirène
je serai le vote à toute allure et
jallet soyez les chats les chiens
j'accouche à une vache détruit
j'enverrai de chevaux je rédigeais des
ordonnances à base de pénicilline
j'étais effectivement avec erin avec une
immense réputation on comprenait car non
seulement que j'étais compétentes me
gêne bouteille mais en plus j'étais je
faisais payer les jambes je t'ai
désintéresse cgt consciencieux bref
c'est une passion qui m'occupait souffle
lorsque brusquement la professeur de
grec à interrompre m
la suite de la version break et je
disais feuilles en propose un diplôme d
ici quatre à quatre vous souriez vous
souriez c'est dans mon rêve d'enfant ce
qui est intéressant d'observer c'est
qu'il y avait certes la compétence je
voulais dit d'ailleurs je vous confie
aussi je crois que ce furent les années
de mes plus grandes réussites
professionnelles mais il y avait aussi
il ya aussi finalement à travers le
désintéressement la conscience
professionnelle l'éthique mais des
professionnels venant en haïti
professionnels vous donnent assad avait
sûrement à charge ils vous connaissez un
vétérinaire qui est votre vétérinaire
traitant et je suis sûr que vous
n'imaginez même pas qu'ils puissent
avoir quelques tournants et si vous
pensez que les dykes c'est une affaire
réservée aux médecins en parle d'éthique
médicale et où pense pas forcément que
le vétérinaire puisse s'interroger avoir
quelques tourments dans ce domaine vous
avez des circonstances atténuantes
l'animal dans notre droit n'a été
reconnue de man être sensible que depuis
1976 dans le code rural est depuis resté
en 2015 dans le code civil il est
toujours considérée en réalité comme un
bien mobilier
en réalité je vais vous dire là je suis
venu précisément vous dire ici que de
nombreuses questions qui relèvent
ce poste au vétérinaire d'abord les
vétérinaires appartiennent à une
profession et de montée qui est
astreinte au respect d'un code de
déontologie qui est imposé par l'état
sous forme d'un décret en conseil d'état
et le manquement au respect de ses
règles de déontologie expose à des
sanctions qui peuvent être très longue
ce qui est intéressant de retenir c'est
que cette technologie est le produit en
réalité de questionnement éthique et
elle reflète à la fois la diversité
facettes de la profession également la
diversité des enjeux de cette profession
paul ricoeur est un philosophe qui s'est
beaucoup intéressée de questions
d'éthique et pour paul ricoeur il y
avait un blanc une référence la moralité
et la moralité antérieurement à ce blanc
de référence il considérait qu'il y
avait il existait il existe une éthique
fondamental qu'il appelle être éthique
antérieures que depuis l'étude
collective et qu'il existe
postérieurement à ce plan de référence d
éthique appliquée qui fait entrer dans
la catégorie de l'éthique postérieur qui
sont autant de questionnements
individuelles bien je vous propose
où je me propose de considérer qu'on
peut appliquer à l'éthique
professionnelle vétérinaire le second
cent pour les vétérinaires le plan de
référence c'est la déontologie
vétérinaire en amont de ce plan de
référence
il y à l'éthique antérieures vétérinaire
cap des petites collectif qui est fait
de tous les questionnements de tous les
débats qui peut avoir lieu dans la
profession et avec les usagers d'un
profession et qui agonise précisément à
écrire neumann un moment donné l'ademe
d'éthologie dans un kot des ruches et
puis après bien sûr il ya la question et
les questions qui se posent à chacun des
vétérinaires isolé voleurs cabinet dans
l'application de ce code de déontologie
et dans le cas du colloque singulier
qu'ils ont avec leurs clients
propriétaires de l'animal
ce sont donc les études postérieures à
pic et donc vous avez compris
il ya d'un côté pour les vétérinaires
une éthique antérieures collective et d
éthique postérieur individuel appliquent
bien moi je vous propose d'illustrer
cette dualité de l'éthique
professionnelle des territoires par
cagdas exemple ou à commencer par des
exemples d'éthique professionnelle
collectés dans la seconde moitié du 20e
siècle
nous avons assisté au développement
d'une agriculture que ce sont toujours
actives en général ou qualifie d'
agriculture productiviste
les paysans sont devenus des exploitants
des producteurs on leur a demandé de
produits
plus tôt en plus l'élevage généralement
intensifs a été qualifiée soit d'élevage
rationnelle soit d'élevage industriel
les vétérinaires dans ces filières se
sont adaptés techniquement j'allais dire
automatiquement assez à ses exigences
ils ont appris notamment un soyez toutes
les maladies qui toutes les pathologies
qui résulte est précisément de ce type
d'élevage obtenir que les débats
techniques ont été plus fréquents plus
abondants que les débats éthiques
et aujourd'hui la profession vétérinaire
veut prendre à la hauteur elle veut
s'insérer dans le débat sociétal tout
elle veut trouver le la voie étroite
la ligne de crête entre son soutien à
l'élevage pour lequel elle a été créée
et en même temps le respect du bien-être
animal
le respect de la relation entre les
humains et les ennemis entre les humains
et la planète
autre exemple
la mondialisation des déplacements de
personnes d'animaux et de produits
zanimos a conduit dans l'eau pays en
europe à l'apparition parfois explosives
de maladies contagieuses transmissibles
aux autres animaux transmissibles dont
seulement à loeb et cela a obligé les
états à prendre un certain nombre de
mesures on appelle des mesures de police
sanitaire
c'est à dire que plutôt que de chercher
à actionner des animaux malades plutôt
que de prévenir la maladie par des
vaccins
on a préféré adopter l'attitude qui
consiste à agir très précocement en
tarissant des sources de virus
supprimant les souverains virus
c'est-à-dire environ en supprimant les
animaux en les tuant entend les hameaux
et anton ceux qui étaient au contact des
animaux infectés malades
cela a donné lieu à des séances d'un
abattage massif que nous avons observées
notamment au royaume uni quand il ya eu
la fièvre aphteuse et ces abattages
massifs ont choqué l'opinion européenne
il était accompagné de spectacles de
charniers fumant lors d'incinération
collective de ces animaux réifier
chosifié si vous préférez en tout cas
dégradée dans le même temps la
profession vétérinaire européennes
globalement est resté avec un silencieux
avoué le silence de cette profession
n'est pas sans me poser un certain
nombre de questions qui vous l'avouerez
relève de la philosophie morale je
voudrais vous citer un autre acte et
dernier exemple de type collective
je vous parlais des nac nac n à ces
nouveaux animaux de compagnie dans le
monde entier les vétérinaires urbain
lounge existe aucun vu leur cabinet
j'allais dire envahi en quelque sorte
rapide on leur a présenté un très grand
nombre de gagnoa soyez qui pouvait être
un hamster de compagnie a raccompagné un
serpent un iguane vert une mygale dit
boire est ce que ces animaux de la faune
sauvage ont bien leur place dans nos
appartements dans nos villes est bien là
encore on avait le déploiement d'une
réponse techniques médicales
considérables biographie est abondante
sur le sujet il y a incontestablement un
hiatus entre la réponse technique de
l'application vétérinaire dans le monde
entier et la réponse éthique ça fait
toujours un peu attendre changeons de
registre et voyons ce qui se passe
ensuite dans l'application du code de
déontologie par chacun des vétérinaires
qui en profitèrent premier exemple de
conflits d'obligations un vétérinaire
conflit d'obligations entre l'exigence
de santé animale sociale à laquelle on
pense aux vétérinaires s'est fait pour
soigner les animaux exigences de santé
animale et exigences de santé publique
ne pas causer par son comportement a
resserré sa grâce et son sa façon de
nous d'agir le risque de maladie pour
les humains vous menez votre chien et je
constate qu'il est atteint de
tuberculose tuberculose tue pour bacille
tuberculeux humains au curry il existe
des traitements
en pratique on sait que nous n'arrivons
pas à le guérir
nous n'aurons pas les moyens matériels
de le guérir notamment dans votre
famille là où il vit avec les
médicaments dont nous disposons est dû
ce faisant si nous insistions si je
commettais l'erreur de vouloir à toute
force foyer de cette maladie je ferais
pourrir le risque finalement d'une
contagion des autres animaux et surtout
une transmission de la maladie à la
famille vous l'avez compris il faut que
j'arrive à me convaincre de procéder à
l'euthanasie
votre chéri je pousse soit contredit
l'article vous imaginez le mien dans le
même temps voilà un exemple de
diabétiques qui se repose dans la
réalisation d'un médecin je pourrais me
donner un autre exemple les vétérinaires
sont parfois amenés dans leur cabinet a
constaté que le chien pour leur amène
est en réalité un animal maltraité
victimes de violences physiques
maltraitance
et quand on sait que la maltraitance
animale est très souvent liée à la
maltraitance humaine vous comprendrez
que la sphère n'est pas mince voyez
encore le dilemme éthique du vétérinaire
qui est partagé entre d'ajouter cette
confiance qu'il accorde son client
confiance protégés par le secret
professionnel et en même temps
l'obligation morale qui l'aurait de
dénoncer cela pour mettre fin à une
maltraitance
je vous donnais un dernier exemple
d'application du code de déontologie
pour un vétérinaire dans son cabinet
c'est là que la question de sa
compétence de sa propre compétence
je suis un vétérinaire généraliste
j'ai eu l'occasion au cours de ma vie
face à des cas peut vous présenter de
réaliser une intervention chirurgicale
j'ai fait deux ou trois fois en 15 ou 20
ans scout ou bien passé mais aujourd'hui
la technique médicale ayant évolué la
profession est organisée différemment et
d'un réseau de spécialistes je sais que
à distance raisonnable
il existe un spécialiste un vétérinaire
spécialiste qui pourrait prendre en
charge le cas d'une façon plus
techniquement élaboré et plus finir et
avec davantage de chances de succès
naturellement dans le cadre de la
relation que j'ai avec mon client lui
apporter toutes les informations à tenir
sur consentement éclairé mais vous
comprenez bien quand même que nous
sommes ici en conscience en dehors des
conflits d'intérêts je crois que je vous
ai donné suffisamment en exemple
pl pour vous faire comprendre le bon de
montrer que finalement les tourments de
nature éthique des vétérinaires
individuellement collectivement sont
multiples variées nombreux sont parfois
fondamentaux ils sont généralement
inconnue ils peuvent être inattendu
l'activité des vétérinaires dans leur
globalité ou individuellement est au
coeur d'une multitude de problématiques
scientifiques c'est juridique ainsi que
de questionnements éthiques qui relève
du conflit une obligation du conflit
d'intérêts que je viens de vous le dire
et tout cela pour quoi asko les
vétérinaires sont au rendez vous de
grands enjeux vitaux la sécurité
alimentaire dans le monde
c'est à dire en réalité la lutte contre
la faim dans le monde la santé animale
c'est ce qui paraît évident à chacun
qu'elles soient au service de l'économie
rurale quand il s'agit des animaux de
rente ou qu'elles soient au service du
bonheur du maître de l'ennemane plus
globalement aujourd'hui et comme
nécessité impérieuse exigé par la
société le bien-être animal et l'a
directement au service des intérêts de
l'allemagne
bien entendu vous l'avez compris la
santé publique de façon fondamentale et
enfin je dirais
plus globalement la santé de la planète
et de la vie et la bri et qu'il faut
respecter
deschamps a mis la formation d'une
éternelle formation initiale dans cet
établissement où formation continue ne
doivent plus se contenter d'être une
formation technique du médecin d'animal
ou de l'ingénieur de l'élevage elle doit
le préparer à la permanence de son
questionnement éthique
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]